الانتخابات الاهم في تاريخ تركيا الحديث
لكل الاطراف الائتلاف الحاكم وزعيمه رجب
طيب اردوغان وللمعارضه في مختلف في
تياراتها لاسيما تحالف الامه في هذه
الفقره نستعرض واياكم اهم التحالفات في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه القادمه اولا
تحالف الشعب او الجمهور يضم حزب العداله
والتنميه بزعامه اردوغان حزب الحركه
القوميه وحزب الاتحاد الكبير وجميع هذه
الاحزاب تنتمي الى تيار اليمين ويمين
الوسط اتفقت هذه الاحزاب منذ البدايه على
شخص اردوغان كمرشح مشترك ولم تشهد حتى
الان اي صراعات او اختلافات فيما بينهم
انضم الى هذا التحالف حزب الدعوه الحره
الاسلامي وهو حزب كردي اسلامي يسمى
اختصارا هدى بار ثم انضم للتحالف حزب
اليسار الاخضر الذي اسسه رئيس وزراء تركيا
الاسبق بولند اجاويد ايضا اعلن حزب رفاعي
الجديد الذي اسسه فاتح اربكان نجل نجم
الدين اربكان مؤسس الاحزاب الاسلاميه في
تركيا اعلن انضمامه لتحالف الشعب ما يعني
انه سيصحف فئه المحافظين لدعم اردوغان
جمهور الاشكال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نذهب معكم الى التحالف الثاني وهو تحالف
الامه المعارض يضم حزب الشعب الجمهوري
اليسار العلماني بزعامه كمال كلتش دار
اوغلو المرشح المشترك لتحالف وحزب الخير
اليمين القومي المتشدد وحزب السعاده
الاسلامي المحافظ والحزب الديمقراطي
القومي اليميني المحافظ وحزب الديمقراطيه
والتقدم وحزب المستقبل بزعامه احمد داوود
اوغلو يعتبر تحالف الامه اكبر تحالف معارض
في تركيا واختار اوغلو مرشحا مشتركا وذلك
بعد خلافات عميقه ما زاد من قوه التحالف
اعلان تحالف العمل والحريه عدم اختيار
مرشح خاص بالرئاسه ودعمه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه وذلك منعا لتشطيط اصوات المعارضه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات